protesters outside parliament
demanding revenge and for iran to stop
nuclear inspections by the international
atomic energy agency
or iaea the anger follows the killing of
top scientist mohsin fakhrezadeh
gunned down by attackers in his car in a
suburb in eastern tehran on friday
his family speaking on state tv also
called for revenge
he was a scientist and at the same time
a very kind and affectionate husband who
loved his country
i plead to others to continue his path
and to not let his blood go in vain
his path was very important for him and
his blood was spilled for it
i tell the world's arrogance that if
they were afraid of this mata
and this country's progress and if they
were worried about progress made by this
mata
you must be scared of his blood a
thousand times more
the world's arrogance has to know that
by killing people like fakhrizadeh
this path of progress will not be
stopped
president hassan rouhani blamed israel
for the assassination of iran's most
senior scientist
the relevant authorities will respond to
this crime in a timely and appropriate
manner
the iranian nation is smarter and wiser
than falling into the trap of the
zionist conspiracy
the supreme leader ayatollah khamenei
also pledged to retaliation
asking for the perpetrators to be firmly
prosecuted and for the work of
fakhrezadeh to continue
iran has launched an investigation in
what is an embarrassing breach of its
security
but political factions differ about what
the response should be
this latest incident will impact on any
plans u.s president-elect joe biden has
for talks with iran
on the nuclear deal known as the joint
comprehensive plan of action
or jcpoa reached in 2015.
i think it will make any negotiations on
the jcpoa
much more complicated and not just from
the american side i think it's going to
be difficult enough for president biden
but it's further complicated by the
reaction
in iran to this killing of one of their
most
senior scientists and you have the
upcoming elections in iran in a few
months
so it's going to make it even more
difficult for the moderates who would
like to see
a patching up of the jcpoa for now
the world is watching and waiting to see
what iran will do next
iran's reformists want to save the 2015
nuclear deal
that means waiting for joe biden to take
office and hope the u.s rejoins and lift
sanctions
the conservatives seem to have run out
of patience and want to stop iaea
inspections others want a strong
response the country has vowed one
but no one knows where when or what form
that will take
assad beg al-jazeera tehran